[Musique]
les shadoks sont en train de disparaître
ils ont attrapé la maladie qui fait
rétrécir en ce temps là c'était facile
il n'y avait pas 36 maladie qu'il n'y
avait la maladie qui servait pour tous
pour les pieds tous les dons pour la
tête et même pour l'intérieur quand un
shadok marché dont la maladie avec ses
pieds tout d'un coup tu chopes qu'il
serait très 6,7 et quand il marchait du
côté où il y en avait moins il serait
précisée - de sorte qu'il serait prêt si
c'est pas partout de la même façon
c'était amusant ses pattes d'abord se
tordait où se ramollit c'est la pauvre
bête se traîner lamentablement coussins
et puis au bout d'un certain temps les
intérieurs étaient attaqués le château
tout entier se grattait maigrissait
maigrissait et la fin disparaissait le
devin poulpe bien aux principes les
réparer avec son robinet magique qu'il
disait pierre
en réalité les jetait tout simplement
gucht
le professeur shadow coup de son côté en
profiter pour lui faire de la
concurrence
il avait soi-disant mis au point un
vaccin
on s'y maladie mais les shadoks inoculé
se gonfle et se gonfler et à la faim
éclater c'était encore plus amusant que
la retraite au même du point de vue de
la santé
si cela continuait le problème du voyage
sur la terre faustus le voyageur allait
être définitivement résolus
[Musique]